supercars
the ultimate driving machine
oh this this car is ridiculous the power
in it is unbelievable
this year supercar dealers have seen
sales top the four
billion pound mark well i'm that racial
i can just blow my nose on them
[Music]
i am selling celebrities footballers
people in the music industry
even actors but who are the men and
women who make
millions from selling these cars without
sounding too
big-headed about things i couldn't spend
the money i've got if i wanted to
what's in the suitcase
you cut me open you've not got blood
coming out of me
you've got super unleaded fuel coming on
me
pumping out what methods do they use to
clinch the million pound deal
he needs a car to take his wife out and
then he needs a car take his girlfriend
this is the girlfriend you know when i
sell a car to a lady
you don't honestly think we talk about
cars do you we talk about
shiny red souls if i'm in bed if i'm in
the shower if i remember trainers
no i wouldn't take 480 five hundred
thousand sterling
phone rings is the deal to be done i'll
do it and how easy is it to succeed in
the cutthroat world
of supercar sales how much does he pay
for this
217 000. once i remember i paid
a million pounds too much for a ferrari
[Music]
at one million six hundred thousand
pounds take your time it's a lot of
money
an exclusive auction house in the center
of london
some of the world's most desirable cars
are being fought over
by some of the world's most wealthy
people
1 650
000 pounds it's here that top supercar
salesman like tom hartley and his son
carl
can be seen hoping to pick up a bargain
hold on congratulations
essentially we own a big toy shop we buy
and sell toys
to people who want to play a top
supercar salesman
can make millions of pounds a year we
deal in
the most expensive supercars in the
world
we deal with the rich we deal with the
famous with the overroyalty
the elite elite
53 year old tom hartley is regarded by
many
as one of the most successful supercar
salesmen
in the country we sold a car that
reached a world record price
of 40 million dollars
i'm not sure that's been beat today
[Music]
home for tom hartley is a specially
designed 40-acre estate
deep in the derbyshire countryside when
you come to them gates
it's been described as the latter's cave
there are two seven-bedroom mansions a
helipad
and arguably one of the most spectacular
garages
in the country this was elton john's
original uh car yet it knew but it was
brand new
um it's a bit of a classic quarter of a
million pounds with the help of his 27
year old son
carl tom hartley sells up to 4 million
pounds worth of vintage and new
supercars
each week this is a ferrari 458 spider
this car was actually a very bespoke car
because of the specification
the paint alone is 9 000 pounds this is
200 000 pounds
the lamborghini aventador probably the
leading in-demand
super rich car to buy and it's 250
000 pounds good morning it's uh
good morning is that um mr lucy
it's tom hartley how are you dad tom
left school at the age of 11
and has been dealing every day since i'm
obsessed about doing deals i'm obsessed
about
buying and selling because that's part
of my life that's why i am a buying sale
i'm a deal maker
[Music]
like his father carl didn't go to
secondary school
instead his dad thought he could give
him a better education on his showroom
floor
he used to sit here i used to be like
you know who was that
and how much how much do you want to pay
and how much is it for sale for and how
much how much did you buy the car for
he's my role model as such you know he's
someone you learn from he's
you know he's everything i know and i
know because
i've well the majority of what i know i
know because i've learned from him
hello how do you do i'm good thank you
carl is now a co-owner in the company
he mostly buys supercars for the
business
monday morning and carl is off to
scotland to buy a ferrari
while dad tom is in london where he will
try to nail his biggest deal of the year
there's a car here for 12 12.5 million
euros
casino owner mr thomas is looking to
invest six and a half million pounds
in an assortment of classic cars this is
a ferrari
detourner a spider that's coming up
now that's about 2 million
what's in the suitcase cash
so why are multimillionaires buying
these cars
the old cars aren't being made anymore
they're all classics they're likely
survived they're van goghs they're
mono's mayonnaise
the chinese market's waking up to
classic cars the russian market
east european it's a lot of people a lot
of money and very limited stock
don't want anything to chief's wrong
word
i wouldn't give you that that's why i
said to you the six and a half million
pound deal
has not been done tom's been sent away
to find better cars
supercars are the ultimate in boys toys
and almost all supercar dealers are men
but there are some women who choose to
enter this testosterone-fueled world
this is the 458 that we've sold saba
amari
runs a supercar showroom in preston
i prep is um quite in depth
so you know we we clean in places where
most people
uh most most dealers wouldn't but i
suppose
it's gonna sound really sexist on tv but
that's a woman's church
it just feels great to be that one
person
that's not the stereotype that's not the
typical rule
all right don't don't dream too much of
the car then over the weekend yeah
okay bye-bye thanks bye
there we go that's one happy customer
coming on monday afternoon
to hopefully do the deal on rf12
sabha admits that she uses her feminine
charm to sell cars
and demonstrates it on a friend you know
it's a car that you can just jump in
it's an enjoyment car absolutely yeah
absolutely my focus is actually on the
whole
lifestyle choice than than just the
vehicle i
firmly believe that anyone coming in to
buy a car
has already decided whether they want it
or not then you live once you work hard
yeah you know come on they're buying
into a lifestyle of luxury aren't they
sabors seeing more and more women buying
supercars
i find whenever when a lady picks up the
phone or comes into the showroom she
knows
exactly what she wants women have very
good taste in cars
do you know when i sell a car to a lady
you don't honestly think we talk about
cars do you
we talk about shiny red souls that's
what we talk about all the time
and handbags and holidays
saber doesn't run this business alone
she does it with her husband
known simply as a maori part of the job
description of my wife is to
do my do my hair as well what side would
you like to do
that's just too smooth to smooth back
inside
the couple married 12 years ago and now
have
two children we have bunny and clyde
that's what we are or mr and mrs smith
with i'm brad pitt and she's angelina
jolie
i wanted to be brad pitt yeah
i'm that passionate about cars i eat
breathe
[ __ ] smell and touch cars
i am a car fanatic the amaris have big
plans to expand
and build another multi-million pound
showroom the new show would be
absolutely fantastic
when a customer buys and buys a car the
cars will come down a glass lift
you know with a cover on it you know and
then there'll be
four girls you know around the car
beautiful girls you know and then
they'll take the covers off and then the
music will come on
and they'll start dancing around the car
and what does your wife think of the
dancing girl
i'm not happy about it at all yeah it's
not been approved at director level yet
at the end of the day they even argue
over which supercar they might like to
drive home
porsche got three three four four
porsches i know
aston martin sabha likes the new cars
but her husband prefers vintage classics
i'll kill them it's important to me what
other people think definitely
let's take the rolls-royce phantom now
and sabha
usually gets her own way
it's a big day for supercar salesman tom
hartley
casino owner mr thomas is on his way to
view more cars
but first what's it like in the hartley
house
this is heartless residence and this is
uh
this is the living room
there's 28 rooms in this house 14 000
square foot
seven bedrooms have all got this
equipment and all got sound system
in every room this is a cinema room
do a lot of entertaining in here this
one room cost 250 000 pounds
to develop
this is me and my wife when i was 50
three years ago
i think i look younger now than i did
casino owner mr thomas has arrived
this is what i'd like to include
[Music]
yeah just to stylish chic tom's been
busy buying more supercars
in the hope that they will impress mr
thomas enough to spend his six and a
half million pound investment fund
this is a 250 ferrari recreation test
rossa
this is a million sterling reproduction
yes it will give you a return you don't
have to include it if you want to
i'd like to include it is mr thomas
willing to part with his millions
the relentless rise of the supercar a
four
billion pound industry fueled by the
desire to go from north to sixty miles
per hour
in just over three seconds
selena is a supercar fanatic with a
garage full of ferraris
it's thrilling it's exciting it's
it's a dream you know that you do have
to pinch yourself and
remind yourself that yes you do own
these cars
[Music]
jonty loves his supercar so much he's
put it in his living room
this is my ferrari 308 gtb
and this is where i keep it
yanny's specially wrapped his ferrari in
gold
just to drive just the feeling you just
feel you feel special you feel nice that
you're you're in this sort of car
and you've worked hard to get there
the increasing demand for these cars
means more and more dealers are trying
to get in on the act
good morning big costume speaking of it
even ordinary garages are seeing an
opportunity to make some serious money
because else can we help you at all
essex dealership big cars normally sell
everything from fiestas to bmws
but boss adam has decided to splash out
300 000 pounds
on three supercars for this new showroom
[Music]
the reason we're moving part of our
business in that direction
is because we know that there's a market
for it i certainly
through running the business of seeing
people screaming out for these kind of
cars
yeah impressive ferrari
not one of the big cars sales team has
ever driven a supercar
let alone sold one they need to up their
game
yeah i don't know an awful lot about
ferraris at the moment but obviously i
have to do some research on them
supercar for anyone again it's you've
got to know your product
you're not going to pick that up
overnight it's a new venture for us
you know but you have to start somewhere
okay
right everybody got you all together
because obviously
exciting time as you all know it's a big
mountain to climb
as well as their normal commission boss
adam is laying on a special bonus
so we're going to get a hundred pound
leg side vouchers behind that card
[Music]
is kevin again um just give me a quick
call just let me know what's happening
spurred on by the lakeside vouchers
salesman kevin thinks he might have a
hot lead if we get a clearance all we've
got to do is really take a deposit on
this car and i'll go for the figures
with you yeah
all right mate good we're nearly there
all right
kevin's hot lead comes good they might
want the 65 thousand pound
audi r8 oh i'll give you a call shortly
see ya
bye bye as well as shopping vouchers
kevin could earn thousands in commission
making this the biggest deal of his life
i think if we can definitely get this
guy on finance
then is evident
this is a 365 gt c4
there's only 28 of these cars ever built
ferrari tom hartley is still working on
the deal with mr thomas
see that view in fact i talked about
that earlier
the condition of this car is absolutely
impeccable for a 50 year old car
do you do you think you can see anything
nicer than that 50 years old i think
i think we should add these um one two
three
four five cars into the package
anyway i'm going to do a calculation for
you has tom done enough to make mr
thomas part with his cash
[Music]
do you want to go with a 6.5 million
purchase on on these these cars
that we've talked about
we've talked about long enough let's get
on with it you want to do that
yeah okay thank you very much pleasure
okay thank you very much simon i
appreciate that
tom's finally got his six and a half
million pound deal
hello but he won't take the day off to
celebrate
what part of the world are you calling
from the united states but i actually
have a eurostat
ferrari f40 sorry f40
yes tom never stops making deals
this is how it is this is me and this is
how i am
tom hartley there's always a deal any
time of the day any hour of the day
if i'm in bed if i'm in the shower if i
remember trainers if i'm having a
massage
if i'm doesn't make any difference if
the deal
phone rings is a deal to be done i'll do
it
tom's been told he needs to relax more
and have regular massages
[Music]
i haven't done this i've got an aneurysm
um which is four millimeters in size
i think i'd give a lot of money not to
have a four millimeter analysis in my
head
but the fact i've got i can't change
that some people want to know
but um i think about all the time
tom's meant to be having a break from
car dealing
hello
okay put an offer to that
guy on the sls roadster
tell him we'd go to 170
000 pounds um and we can pick up
tomorrow
come you have a massage but you don't
actually seem to be working there are
some cars coming in
cars gone out took a couple of ferraris
and i bought a couple of cars whatsapp
the hour-long massage is only just
getting started
yeah five hundred thousand
five hundred thousand sterling about
five hundred thousand euros
no i wouldn't take 480 thousands five
hundred thousand sterling
no not four hundred ninety thousand five
hundred thousand
yep no i know i appreciate it but that's
that's the price of it
do you want it yes five hundred thousand
okay
cheers thank you very much cheers help
me through
what happened it was quite simple wasn't
it that was the place the guy do you
want if you don't want it
you're just going to be shaped to the
point and that's how it is that's how i
buy my cars that's how it's on the
some people love it some people love it
next it's to the showroom
to complete the paperwork
[Music]
tom's not the only one making millions
out of supercars
the amari is at one of the most
successful supercar dealers in the
country
if you're dealing with supercars you've
got to be living in a super house
you're going to be wearing super clothes
you're gonna wear super watches
you've got to talk super you're going to
meet with super people you're going to
act super
you know everything in your life has to
be super you've got to be a superman
that's what our lifestyle is super
they've spent millions on their
state-of-the-art house
yep this is all my hard work spent quite
a long time
getting it well up to this level it's
packed full of the latest
most expensive gear we've got control 4
which runs
everything in the house so you can
control all your lights
it works by our ipads iphones we've got
3d tvs throughout the house so you can
watch everything in 3d and these are
really cool
glasses these are the fiesta resistance
is saba's ultra modern kitchen
this is my favorite room of the house
yeah we've got around about i think
700 likes in the house
spotlights led lights oh god i love it
i love it put the led lights on
i say if this kitchen was a car
it would be the bugatti of all kitchens
[Music]
sabha sells millions of pounds worth of
the latest supercars
every week
sabe is our super car sales woman she
sells to the super rich
the super rich men the super rich women
she's um
the heart of the business while saba
specializes in selling amari dabbles in
buying
the fact about this car is that this car
was
owned by rod stewart and today this is a
cool
1.3 million but sabha thinks he
overspends
i might pay a bit more money for a car
than what i should do
once i remember i paid a million pound
too much for a ferrari
and she hit the roof she was what the
hell have you done that for
today amari's got his eye on an old
classic
ferrari i'm not keen on you buying that
car if i'm honest with you
really saba does have a reservation
about me buying classic cars you can
imagine when somebody's dealing in more
than modern supercars
they're everyday supercars she's um
she's always had a reservation about it
doesn't sound attractive to me
i think i keep amari on the straight and
narrow definitely
he's right out there so sometimes after
just reeling back in a little bit
sabbah puts her foot down amari can't
have
his half million pound ferrari
one of the uk's leading supercar
salesman tom hartley
has built a multi-million pound mansion
50 yards from it
is another mansion almost exactly the
same
like his dad carl has spent millions on
his house
i designed a lot of it my wife designed
most of it
everything above ground is all my wife
below ground is is me you know this
is known as carlito's way
as you'll see at the top at the top of
the bar this is um
this is where i come you know i
socialize my friends come around we have
a drink
you know we had to celebrate good deals
or drown our sorrows with bad deals
it was built to the specification being
completely soundproof
so no complaints from neighbors no
complaints from
me dad next door at three o'clock in the
morning because i know
it'd be like turn it down
go to bed along with his brother and
sister
carl left primary school and joined his
dad's business
the families soon caught the media's
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your name tom tom carl
priscilla and uh you're all the same
family the hartley family and
you you're all in the same business
aren't you together yeah yeah
and how old are you carl seven what do
you do in the business
well um when i come home from school um
i say i go in show him see if we bought
any cars or something
i actually can't even watch this
[Laughter]
i can't even speak on it i just know
i was only a baby i was seven carl met
his wife mitzi
when they were teenagers your dad would
show me a car that he's bought today or
sold today or
or tell me what she's done then we'd get
in the car we're going to play golf
maybe get some food out and come back
you know just how old would you be
oh this is why this would start from
when i was six i was sick i'm sick yeah
have you created your children in your
own image
no i wouldn't say that i would say that
they've been them
given an opportunity to make best of
um and opportunities available to them
and they've taken advantage of that
opportunity
but in bringing them into here and
training them in the hartley school's
life
you taught them about the deal and
prioritize the deal
no i i don't see how i don't see i i
taught them what what
i told them what i think they need to do
in life
i left because i wanted to leave school
i wasn't learning anything i was wasting
wasting time for me in school
carl's been taught about the world of
supercars by the best
and now he's mainly the buyer for the
business carl's very good at his
business
and predominantly he does more buying
than he does selling
but he does do both if he has to do and
he can do both
tom's illness means that he's been told
to slow down and let
carl do more i was warned by the doctors
that my lifestyle and my attitude
or my approach maybe i had to take more
of a back seat
but taking a back seat is not proving
easy for tom
i love my life i love waking up in the
morning i love
challenges i love adventure
i love gambling and i love
taking a risk maybe you should slow down
that time
slow down maybe i'll take your advice
i don't think i will
so that there's no crossed wires please
put it on an email to me
i will address it as soon as possible
okay it's saturday morning
and sabha omari is hard at work in the
office dealing
with a tricky customer but i need to
understand what your concern is now from
what i can understand
you think you've paid over list for the
car
you haven't because the list price on
the car is 87 you've paid 82.
okay while sabbah's in preston running
the business
her husband amari's down in london at a
classic supercar auction
with his sales manager ali that's a
beautiful coloured combination
i like that car as well
[Music]
i think if you cut me open you've not
got blood coming out of me you've got
super unleaded fuel coming on me pumping
out
that's a nice car though
a few years ago amari bought a ferrari
for a million pounds more than it was
worth
yeah yeah not too bad i think amari's
deals are
from the heart and my deals are from the
head
this time omaree has fallen in love with
a maserati
once owned by benny from 70s pop group
abba
[Music]
and then dancing queen as well yeah
dancing queen the dog give me give me
give me give me yeah yeah
super nice city i'm a nice city that was
jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy
give me give me give me
decision made the pair head off for a
bite to eat
but during lunch bidding for the abba
car gets underway
down here's something
on the way home yeah we'll play ours
on the way home
[Music]
but all's not lost omari falls head over
heels
for a classic ferrari 246 dino
gtb it's the original color which is
dino blue
yeah very rare amari is determined not
to let this one go
any movies
omari is delighted with his new car but
now
he has to convince sabba it was a good
deal
we do discuss the buying process of
course you know if i feel that a
particular car
isn't going to be for us then i'll tell
him so i'd rather not do
a deal than do a bad deal it's the
original blue dino the color
it's not it's not
spending any available okay i'd be a
profit on this car
she kind of like flipped a little bit
but i know about the right decision all
right then
see you then bye bye bye bye
see every decision that i make is for
the betterment of the business
so a bad deal for me would be a no-go
back at big cars the grand plan to sell
supercars
could be paying off you've got to be
in a different class of driving things
terry and caz are trying out the 180 000
pound ferrari
just press that button there and that's
it yeah yep listen to this
is this what you two have coming to buy
today now we've come to buy before focus
[Music]
james is left still chasing that elusive
supercar sale
but senior salesman kevin seems to be
having better luck the next
thing we're going to do is get you
propped on fine so i need some details
from you
he's found someone who wants the audi r8
and now he's waiting for the finance to
go through
are you lose good news bad news
we like to prolong the pain
kevin could earn thousands in commission
on this deal so he's desperate for it to
go through
but now rival adam's got a strong lead
too
we've done some figures for the finance
um good news is we can get to
pretty much where you want to be on a
monthly basis so it's coming out at 1099
a month
adam's already got someone on the r8 but
my guy could
steam him first so it's a bit of a
doggy dog situation right okay no
problem like i said
we definitely went to the best we could
oh yes but obviously
if you can't quite get to the payment
yeah it's not the end of the world
adam's potential buyer drops out cheers
thanks fight was that your name yeah
oh i like that oh baby baby
[Laughter]
and uh he can only go to 950 a month in
touch with him but yeah
it's all on you now mate oh my
pressure's on
yeah back at home kevin has been telling
his wife claire and his daughter gracie
that he could be bringing home
a large amount of money what do you
think you might spend on
um we'd like to do some things to the
house and
do the lounge and uh yeah probably have
a nice holiday somewhere
where would you go you know it's florida
where you'd like to go to disneyland
and maybe something like that will kevin
be able to seal the deal
and take his family to disneyland
[Music]
well i hope you got that on camera
supercar salesman tom hartley
is following doctor's orders and taking
some time out
[Music]
of the tiger woodshop his sons are
joining him for a round you think
they're better at golf than you are
yeah i better go from there they are now
they never used to be i'm getting a bit
older
oh and he's better at cars house oh
that's a silly question to ask on camera
in other words the daddy
he's supposed to who is better than the
dad in the castles
nobody and tell them i said so
may be the best supercar salesman but
he's trying to take more of a back seat
in the business
[Music]
mostly buys rather than sells supercars
but today
tom's letting him try to sell a
lamborghini to businessman
mr white yeah nice to meet you i'll even
look at you
yeah thank you tom's going to keep out
of the way
inside just got everything you know it's
it's just got
whatever you want yeah that's pretty
funny
he car to take his wife out and then he
needs a car take his girlfriend out in
that's the difference this is the guy
this is the girlfriend card definitely
the girlfriend car
okay mr lee down
carl's done the deal with mr white but
while they've been talking
tom receives a better offer from one of
his contacts
by phone how much does he pay for this
217 thousand
chief tucci he's a friend i think you've
been too good of a deal
you think i do i'm actually tempted to
buy the back off you know if you want to
sell it so if you want to have a quick
pop on it
listen miss hartley thank you very much
but um this particular car
are you saying you don't want the 5 000
prop on the car now and even where it is
i'm saying that as much as i'd love five
thousand pounds this morning
um i think this car is for me but thank
you
very much appreciate nonetheless so you
haven't actually taken the car the
showroom you've got to just agree to buy
it and i'm okay five thousand pound
profit
yes you are you don't want to take it no
not today but i will give you a call
as soon as i go to sell it you're the
first person i've found i promise you
that
cheers thank you tom's effort to let
carl do the deal on his own
hasn't lasted long he just can't help
himself
the buzz after a deal lasts about five
seconds maybe 15 seconds
that instinct feeling and then it
disappears and you think about
getting that buzz again the next deal
you're addicted to that bus
i think you probably am that's the truth
being on
deal maker tom is struggling to loosen
the reins and allow carl to do more
in the business
good good yeah not bad at all back at
big cars
things aren't going so well for kevin's
supercar deal
we just want commitment but you're going
to buy because all it's done to me
really
really mate is i've gone into my boss
i've said yeah the man's buying a [ __ ]
and it makes me look complete idiot
you can understand that well no i it has
because my boss is saying well i thought
we had this still
kevin's customer is messing him around
i give up with my art just getting tired
of a bloke huh
well we negotiated heavily on the price
he wanted two grand off
got that for him wanted a warranty got
that for him and now
he's faffing around he's saying there's
found somewhere local audi
that's got the same car with one owner
and les miles
i'm really disappointed but we're in
this situation
um you know i want to settle the car but
kevin
wants his commission he stays late to
convince the buyer to commit
[Music]
but with no luck
like he says i'm pissed off we still
haven't done a deal
and yeah it's getting a bit to the point
now where i just want to
chuck it all in just like take what
[Music]
[Music]
fiesta
a fleet of extraordinary vehicles are
making their way to the mecca of
supercar enthusiasts
tom hartley's showroom
[Music]
every year he opens his door to a group
of supercar collectors who can catch a
glimpse of his incredible garage
[Music]
tom's trying to take more of a back seat
in the business
this is a chance for son carl to shine
and be the day's main
seller you're hoping to get a few deals
yeah fingers crossed
we'll get a deal or a couple today get
their wife drunk and
then they'll let their husbands buy
whatever they want
tom's wife priscilla knows it's not easy
for her husband to stay in the
background
he's a self-professed deal addict
what's it like to be to be married
on a day-to-day basis this um
[Music]
up and down i suppose you just get used
to it after a while
i imagine he works pretty hard oh yeah
24 7.
she said we don't go on holidays i just
moved my office to other parts of the
world
everything
[Music]
with cars looks wise i don't think
anything
can compete with an event at all i think
that's just the best you know full aston
martin service history and it's you know
you like it you don't have any problems
with it
it's near the end of the day and carl's
not sold anything yet
his plan of stepping up and selling more
isn't panning out
big cars in essex and after days of
negotiation
kevin's got some news money's money's
free we just found out it's good
we're all good to go he sold his first
ever supercar for 65 000 pounds
all right happy with that
yeah all right enjoy the car all right
thanks for your
business and i'll speak to you soon yeah
really [ __ ] in there absolutely fine
finally finally finally five days of
half slog that was
that's good excellent done it
get it on the boat oh yeah let's go and
celebrate and tick it off
right okay last part let's put it on the
ball
it's all done
won the lakeside vouchers and his
commission
oh he's got thousands of pounds coming
his way
the amari's are spending their
commission from supercar sales
on a state-of-the-art showroom building
is underway
75 ferraris lamborghinis poaches
all the supercars that you can think of
you know how much i love lights
oh my god i dread to start ordering the
light bulbs
led bulbs whatever you call them no no
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go to led all led lights
you know everywhere it's gonna look
awesome isn't it
a few days later amari's blue ferrari a
recent auction purchase
arrives wow
look at that colour of that car dino
blue
that's a beautiful woman that's an old
but glamorous classy lady
starts up now
that's absolutely beautiful now omari
has to show it to his wife sabha
who was furious that he bought it in the
first place
when the car arrived and it kept the
transporter
luckily she wasn't there hi
come back thanks for you darling you're
okay
[Music]
okay great
[Music]
sabbah checks out the dino
these cows were born to be driven born
to be
loved born to be cherished for cared for
the works of art what do you think of
the dino
it's beautiful you like it initially
i was a little bit reluctant about the
classic cars but yeah when he turned up
or when the car turned up it was like a
pleasant surprise
and but it is a fabulous car and i
believe in amari's judgment and i'm sure
it'll be quite a rewarding investment
amari's out of the doghouse
don't do it again don't do it again bye
bye
without telling me don't you forget that
[Music]
to celebrate being back in sabah's good
books amari is taking the blue ferrari
for a spin
here's an 8 track here eric clapton i've
owned a couple of his ferraris as well
[Music]
can you believe that's working
awesome i feel great
i feel fantastic i feel
super
[Music]
to put your foot down on the clutch okay
it's been three weeks since kevin sold
his first supercar
but there's some news he's left big cars
and gone to another garage to sell
family motors again
well we can do a test drive for you
buying up a test drive see if you like
the car
all right the dream of making big money
out of supercars
wasn't for him it's been a bit of a
roller coaster i must say
yes you can earn money out of it but
money's not everything is
you know it's gonna be happy what you do
as well gotta be happy in what you do
supercars not for me not for me at all
don't do it for me
for you no not really no yeah
but kevin's commission from the audi r8
means they're still planning
on going to disneyland yeah
back at the hartleys and the group of
supercar collectors
are preparing to go home
if you want to buy it you can if you
don't want to then i've got it for sale
anyways
okay yeah that's fine carl wants to
prove he can sell as well as his dad but
he's only got a few minutes left to
clinch a deal
and sell a car
there's a couple i think he talked about
bentley convertibles
the sl65 black series so you know
i've just left them to it let them look
around the car and
uh yeah they like it so they should like
the price and i think he's coming back
now
you come in the office yes now
carl's got a chance of selling two cars
right coming to the house
he has to negotiate for half an hour
so i think he's the uh new owner of an
sl 65 black series
and a bentley v8 gtc so yeah
it's um good day good deal
it's a massive deal and carl tells his
dad the good news
i tell you what well done thank you it's
good well done until tomorrow
carl's got his first handshake in a long
time
but he knows his dad isn't ready to hand
over the keys to the business yet
he'll no no no he'll never leave he's
never going to turn around one day and
say you know what
i've had enough and i'm just going to
stay at home today like that's just not
him
he just he just doesn't do it it's clear
he'll have to wait quite some time
before his dad relinquishes control
for me i'll always be buying and selling
if when i leave this
showroom in in my coffin and
i want to make sure i'm dead because i
might just put my hand out and say
deal's still available who knows
[Music]
so
[Music]
you